so I was sitting down earlier today and
I was thinking about the road to age of
apocalypse I was thinking about all
these videos that we were going to have
to do and all these things we were going
to have to discuss and I realized that
we have a problem the problem is that we
had no method of organization we had no
standard as to how these videos were
going to be done I didn't really know
who I was going to talk about I didn't
know what order I was going to talk
about with regards to those characters I
didn't know if I was going to do groups
or any of that kind of stuff and when I
went through and I looked at all the
comments that you guys had left
everything became pretty clear
everything seemed to make a lot of sense
a lot of you guys wanted me to talk
about groups a lot of you guys wanted me
to talk about characters a lot of you
guys wanted me to talk about prominent
members and groups but not the group
itself and so what we're going to do
here is we're going to we're going to
use this flowchart to tell us exactly
how it is that we're going to do the
road to age of apocalypse series that
will lead us to the Age of Apocalypse
proper so the first thing we're going to
be talking about are the groups now the
reason why we're going to be to using
groups here is because with the Age of
Apocalypse these groups that you see
listed are the companions or i guess the
earth-616 version of the groups that
will appear in the age of apocalypse now
these are listed as the earth-616 groups
and the reason why is because everywhere
to explain the age of apocalypse groups
we'd basically be explaining the age of
apocalypse and so we need to have
something for you guys to reference we
need to have something that can be
looked at so you can say okay this is
what they're liking the age of
apocalypse but this is what they're like
in the main earth-616 universe and so
the groups that we're going to be
talking about our X Factor Excalibur
Generation X New Mutants Morlocks the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants the Horsemen
of apocalypse and the Marauders now with
the age of apocalypse some of these
groups are actually named different in X
Factor the group is called factor X and
they exist under the EMF Excalibur is
spelled x-caliber KSCA li bu are with
Generation X is called Generation Next
but again these are more or less just
companions the element of the team
remains the same in terms of the
relation to the earth-616 universe
they're just different here because
they're composed of different members or
they play different roles now after
we've discussed the
groups we're going to move on to the
most prominent members or the leaders of
these groups and the reason why I chose
these two categories prominence and
leadership is because some of these
groups don't have real leaders per se
there's simply just a band of characters
who have come together and then call
themselves something with the Morlocks
for example there's no real leader of
the Morlocks per se we could reference
Callista we could say Callisto may be
the leader of the Morlocks for the most
part but Omega Red is a far more
prominent character than Callisto is and
so we're going to be talking about a
mega red as we get into the Morlocks
with the new mutants we're going to be
talking about Psylocke or of course
going to get into a cyclops with X
Factor because in the Age of Apocalypse
under the group factor X Cyclops is the
most battle-hardened and best warrior
that they have of course with Excalibur
we'll see night crawler and so on and so
forth now after we're done talking about
the prominent or the leaders of these
groups then we're going to get into all
the other members of these groups and if
you're curious to see who it is that are
featured in these groups you can of
course look that up on Wikipedia now
from here after we're done talking about
all the members of these various groups
we're going to get into everybody else
anybody else that plays any kind of a
significant or minor role in in this
story of course we're going to talk
about sugar man we're going to talk
about destiny we're going to talk about
juggernaut now I know a lot of you were
surprised to see the juggernaut is going
to be listed under the major and minor
characters and is it going to be at the
top of the list here but the reason why
is because in the Age of Apocalypse
juggernauts a monk and he actually takes
a group to visit destiny who is a
precognitive she can see the future and
so this story is going to play out in
such a way that jumper not scoring not
going to have a huge role he's not going
to be as big as x-man for example or
Magneto with some of these groups with
the I'm sorry some of these individuals
we're going to get into the two
characters like Bishop we're going to
get into characters that exist for the
most part in a way where we just really
can't categorize them we really can't
quantify that Bishop is an individual
that's going to help rectify the Age of
Apocalypse timeline but he doesn't
really belong to any one group he allies
himself with the x-men that's really
about it
you know and because we've talked about
the x-men already there wasn't really a
reason to list them on this on this
chart now from here the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to get
into the individual members of the x-men
that are not listed on this chart that
are not listed in any other group on
this or any other part of any of these
groups so what I mean by this is we're
going to be talking about magneto for
example we're going to be talking about
rogue we're going to be talking about
these characters who are part of the
x-men team in the Age of Apocalypse but
none of them will be listed as part of
any of these groups I don't know if that
makes any sense to you guys but again if
you're unsure about who I'm talking
about then you can go to Wikipedia look
at the age of apocalypse teams and all
those individuals that are listed as
part of the x-men other characters we
will be talking about before we get to
any of these other groups so with that
being said I hope this video was clear
as mud and I will catch you guys later
peace
you